a sense of calm after over three weeks
of unrest
is set up by Serbian protesters that
blocked the main roads in Northern
Kosovo are being taken down
the agreement to remove the barricades
was reached during Serbian president
Alexander vuja's visit to the border on
Wednesday when he met with the leaders
of the Serbian community in Kosovo
because naturally
it means that from tomorrow in the
morning hours the removal of barricade
will begin this is not simple and it
cannot be finished in two hours of some
sort but either in 24 or 48 Hours the
barricades will be removed
however a few rows are still closed
despite the deal the K4 International
peacekeeping Force Under the command of
NATO is urging the Serbian and Kosovo
governments to abide by the agreement
the region has been on the edge since
July after the kosovan government made
kosovan license plates mandatory for all
residents outlawing license plates
issued in Serbia the kosovan serves in
the territories North especially in
mitrovitsa protested as a result
tensions flared again nearly three weeks
ago when a Serbian former police officer
was detained by kosovan authorities for
suspected role in attacks against ethnic
Albanian officers protesters blocked
roads and cut off the connection between
Kosovo and Serbia in the northern Kosovo
city of Metro vitza service make up the
majority of the population and Serbian
Flags hang in the streets and from walls
and balconies as well as government
buildings Muslims fit their vehicles
with the license plates issued by the
Serbian government rather than use
Kosovo ones all this suggests the
kosovan government has little authority
here
owner of a coffee house in mitrovitsa
Alexandra arcenevich says that local
serbs want to join Serbia
most serbs here want to join Serbia
because it's been 22 years of forced
integration and it failed we're denied
our Democratic rights by kosovan
authorities and are subject to many
other rights violations
however dushan milanovich amitrovitsa
Municipal councilman who spoke with me
along the IBA river that divides the
city's Serbian and Albanian sites blames
both Pristina and Belgrade
there is discrimination against serbs
but Belgrade also manipulates the
Serbian population in Kosovo and causes
the unrest the main problem here is that
Serbia doesn't recognize Kosovo as an
independent state Belgrade is in pursuit
of its own interests and endangering the
stability here
in albanians and serbs in the northern
Kosovo region a tennis piece has been
established since the country's
Declaration of Independence in 2008 and
with some roads still blocked that
fragile piece is at stake if broken it
can lead to conflict in region and
Beyond Russell said that Al Jazeera
mitrovitsa Northern Kosovo